Now when you take a guy who's working as
a truck driver and he's making $50,000
a year and you tell him that automation
is going to take away his job,
but good news,
we're going to give you $12,000 a year.
That's a substantial loss in
income and yeah, it leaves them.
Yeah. It also leaves them with
this feeling of uselessness
or hopelessness that
they're not contributing.
You know?
I think one of the things that people
enjoy is a earning their own way.
You know, they, they, people
don't, it sounds counterintuitive.
People don't like free money. They'd
like a feeling of satisfaction of a job.
Well done that they've created
something that they've done something.
Yeah, you're 100% right. It's one reason
why we call this the freedom dividend.
We say, look, it's not money for nothing.
You're an owner and shareholder of the
richest country in the history of the
world. Just like when I buy Verizon
or Microsoft, they send me a dividend.
Like I don't complain about that.
Like your now a shareholder in this
great nation and you get a dividend.
But when I was with Dennis,
the trucker who owns his own
trucking company in Iowa, uh,
the,
the role that job's playing in
truckers' lives is vital. And again,
I'm a very data driven guy where
men deal with joblessness very,
very poorly by the numbers we spend
between 40 and 75% of our time on the
computer playing video games
or doing other things, uh,
are substance abuse, goes up, are
volunteering in the community, goes down,
even though we have more time and we
generally spiral into antisocial and self
destructive behaviors. Now this
is not something that's, uh,
experienced by women in the same
levels like women and joblessness.
Women actually have more adaptable.
They're more likely to go
back to school and volunteer.
They don't spend all their time on
the computers the way that we do.
So there's a real problem.
Uh,
and the purpose of universal basic income
is not meant to be a job replacement
for those truckers because
right now those truckers,
and when I talked to the truck drivers,
so I've been campaigning for
president now for a number of months.
So I spent a lot of time in Iowa,
which is a really huge trucking hub.
And you go to them and say,
hey guys,
you worried about robot trucks
taking your jobs? They're like,
there's no way rubble. I could take
my job like that. That's, you know,
that's like totally matter of
fact, they're like, they're like,
this is not something
that they worry about.
Their attitude has transitioned
from that somewhat too. Uh,
we should make robot trucks illegal or
we should make it so that a robot truck
cannot displace me.
So that's been a big shift because a
year ago they were like, it's impossible.
The idea that an American would say
we should make a a robot job illegal.
Like it's,
we should have some laws that keep you
from being free to use robots for your
business instead of person.
Like you should be forced to
highly mandatory unionization
or something. That sounds
pretty ridiculous. Well,
that's where a lot of the Marjoe, uh,
so only 13% of truckers are unionized.
So 87% are like Dennis where
there are small independent firms.
And a lot of them actually, uh,
bought or leased their own trucks.
So they took out tens of thousands of
dollars in the equivalent of a mortgage to
get this truck. And so if they have
to compete against a robot truck,
that doesn't stop. That's like, you
know, that's existential level stuff.
And right now truck drivers have time
use regulations where they cannot drive
more than 14 hours a
day. Uh, so you can't,
you literally cannot compete because
the robot trucks just gonna keep going.
Our 15, 16, 17, et cetera.
So these guys make,
some of them make really good money.
Like some of them make 70, 75, $80,000.
It's one of the higher paying jobs for,
um,
men without a college degree.
And so if you look at what they're facing,
it's not so crazy that they're like,
hey, you need to make the
robots illegal because for them,
what is the next best
economic alternative?
If the robot trucks take over that job,
like what are they going to go from? Yeah.
It's not crazy for them,
but it's a crazy idea to tell a company
that they can't do something that's more
efficient, safer, and probably
economically more viable. Oh yeah.
Again,
the savings from automating truck driving
are estimated to be $168 billion per
year and not just labor savings,
but also equipment utilization because
the trucks never stop fuel efficiency
because the trucks can daisy chain
together, so there's less wind resistance,
fewer accidents,
cause right now truck accidents
kill about 4,000 people a year,
so you'd probably save lives.
There's a very,
very powerful argument for the fact that
we should be trying to automate this
stuff,
but on the other side you have literally
three and a half million truckers who
apply upon this further livelihoods to
support their family and there's going to
be a lot of passion,
a lot of resistance to this.
Anyone who thinks that truck drivers
are just going to shrug and be like,
all right, I guess I had a good run. I'm
just going to go home and figure it out.
That's not going to be their response.
Right?
It's going to be much more likely that
they say you need to make these robot
trucks illegal or they're just going to
park their trucks across the highway,
get their guns out. Cause a lot of these
guys are ex military and just be like,
Hey, like I'm not moving my
truck until uh, you know,
I get my job back and that there'll be
a lot of truckers in the same situation.
You really think that would happen?
Well I think they blocked the highway for
their job back. That's less efficient.
Kills more people. So I was with these
truckers in the truck stop in Altoona,
Iowa and Joe, they have really,
really difficult jobs. I mean,
I don't know if you knew truckers
where you were, but they,
they have this 14 hour window where
they're allowed to drive their truck and
they drive most of that.
So they have these other 10 hours
and they sleep in their truck,
their trucks have a bed, they go into the
truck stop, they take a shower, you know,
there's a laundry and they're like
plugged into this machine of this truck of
and, and the industry,
you know, they spend days,
sometimes weeks on the road.
A lot of them listen to podcasts.
Probably a lot of them
listening right now.
A lot of them listened to podcasts and uh,
they're doing it primarily because it's
a more lucrative opportunity than the
other jobs that are available to them.
A lot of them have families that like,
you know, like the support of their
families. Uh, and so if you say,
hey guys, like, you know, Time's
up for, for this way of life.
Most of them I think will
not like, uh, like, uh,
actually I look at how much they
frankly they like into your,
there's so much endurance baked into that
job that I think most of them will be
like some of the guys you and I know
where they're much more likely to like
implode or like, you
know, do something where,
where it's self destructive than they
would be to take their truck in La,
you know,
park it across the highway.
But you're talking about a
population of hundreds of thousands,
including many small business owners and
small business owners have a different
mentality very often.
Like I've been an entrepreneur,
I'm a serial entrepreneur
for the last 20 years.
Like you're an entrepreneur and if you
saw this happen, you might say, Hey,
I'm adaptable. I'll figure it
out. Or you might say, Hey,
I think I can do something about this.
Like if I parked my truck this way,
like that's going to cause
such havoc that it's, you know,
it's like hundreds of millions of dollars
worth of economic harm very, very fast.
And if you look at the
industrial revolution,
which people site as the precursor
to what we're going through,
there were mass riots in the industrial
revolution that killed dozens of people,
caused billions of
dollars worth of damage.
Labor Day's a holiday today
because of those riots.
And then we implemented universal high
school in 1911 in part as a response to
these riots.
So according to the estimates,
this is called the fourth
industrial revolution,
and we're going to displace jobs at
three to four times the rate of that
industrial revolution.
And that industrial revolution
included mass riots.
So thinking that this one
will not strikes me as really,
really optimistic and perhaps unrealistic.